10 million people in the city
and you can't find a single ordinary
person to work in the newspapers or work
in the skyscrapers right
we've developed a system
where we basically funnel kids from rich
families into private schools and elite
jobs without ever really stopping to ask
are these guys any [__] good
and listen i can guarantee you in the
majority of cases these guys they know
how to look smart they know how to talk
smart but they never started thinking
once in their lives
they just walked into these spaces you
know what i mean so then the end result
is it's not a conspiracy it's a it's a
[__] idiocracy
honestly that's what it is
like it's a bunch of
guys that
wear nice suits and have nice haircuts
patting each other on the back and
saying aren't we all so [__] smart
and being wrong year after year after
year after year after year
and i almost wish it was a conspiracy
because the truth is in a way more
horrific than that which is just
there's kids all over the sea that are
smarter than the guys in those
newspapers and in those skyscrapers and
they're being wasted